me acaba de llegar la noticia de que
unos rompecabezas 3d que me encantan
están en oferta y quiero saber cuánto
van a costar yo sé que normalmente cada
uno cuesta 180 y me dijeron que tenían
un 25% de descuento vamos a averiguar
cuánto me van a costar con la oferta
lo más increíble de los porcentajes es
que hay muchas maneras de llegar al
resultado te voy a explicar varias que
he ido descubriendo poco a poco es decir
100 por ciento equivale a decir todo o
el total en este caso el total serían
los 180 que normalmente cuesta un
rompecabezas la primera manera de
resolver planteamientos con porcentajes
es cuando tenemos que calcular un tanto
por ciento que sea divisor de 100
como el 10 que resulta de dividir 100
entre 10 el 50 que es el 100 entre 2 o
como el descuento los rompecabezas que
es el 25 por ciento y es divisor de 100
porque 100 entre 4 es igual a 25
únicamente debes identificar entre
cuántos se divide el 100 así que no
perdamos de vista el 4 va a estar muy
fácil solo por la atención como 100
entre 4 es igual a 25
entonces si divido el 180 entre el 4 el
resultado será el 25 por ciento esto es
porque los porcentajes siempre serán
proporcionales
es decir si de un lado aumenta del otro
lado también y en la misma proporción
así que si de un lado se divide entre el
4 del otro lado también es tan fácil que
es casi mágico así obtenemos el 25% de
180 que es 45
los rompecabezas costarán sólo 45 creo
que olvidó algo están demasiado baratos
claro lo que pasa es que 45 no es el
precio con oferta de los rompecabezas es
solo el descuento es decir la cantidad
que disminuye el precio original quiere
decir que me hace falta otro paso y es
restarle los 45 del descuento a 180 así
ya sé que el precio que tendrán será de
135 y lo que me ahorraré son los 45 que
calculamos al principio
muy bien ya que me estás ayudando con
los porcentajes fíjate que compraré dos
rompecabezas pero el precio que tenemos
es sin iva al momento de pagar se cobra
un impuesto del 16 por ciento esta es
una cantidad que se suma al total y es
lo que realmente hay que pagar
primero hay que definir el 100% es decir
el total de la compra como son dos
rompecabezas y todavía alcanzó la oferta
del 25% de descuento son dos de 135 o
sea 270 perfecto ya identificamos el
total o sea el 100% para calcular el iva
hay que calcular el 16% de 270 como 16
no es divisor de 100 te explicaré otro
método
lo primero que debemos hacer es dividir
el porcentaje entre 100 y 1 por cada
porciento para obtener un decimal y esto
es lo más fácil del mundo solo hay que
recorrer el punto decimal dos lugares a
la izquierda porque porque al dividir
entre múltiplos de 10 los ceros nos
indican los lugares a la izquierda que
debemos recorrer así que al dividir
entre 100 tenemos dos lugares a la
izquierda recorremos un lugar y se
convierte en 1.6 luego otro lugar y
tenemos el punto 16 que es igual a 16
entre 100 este es el número que hará la
magia solo tenemos que multiplicar
nuestro total por el porcentaje en
decimal es decir el 270 por el punto 16
y tendremos el 16%
así que 43.2 es el impuesto que se tiene
que pagar por los dos rompecabezas para
saber el total a pagar hay que sumar
este 43.2 al 270 para tener el costo ya
con impuestos o sea 300 13.2 verdad que
es muy fácil y espérate que tengo otro
método para dar métodos que no vas a
creer que funcionan por los fáciles que
son
para sorprenderte aún más te enseñaré mi
método especial para ofertas e impuestos
yo lo llamo porcentaje directo aunque tú
le puedes poner otro nombre vamos a
tomar los dos ejemplos del principio
para que veas que no hago trampa con el
resultado
primero calculamos el precio con el 25%
de descuento de un rompecabezas que
cuesta 180 aquí la clave está en
determinar cuál será mi porcentaje final
como 180 es mi total o sea mi 100%
le voy a restar al 100 el 25% de
descuento quiere decir que lo que voy a
pagar ya con el descuento es el 75 por
ciento del precio original ok y ya no
cálculo primero el 25% y luego lo resto
solo calculó el 75% y tengo mi resultado
entonces tenemos que multiplicar 180 por
punto 75 ya que recorrimos dos lugares
el punto decimal y el resultado de esta
multiplicación es 135 ya viste que fue
el mismo resultado para el caso de oliva
es igual de sencillo solo tomamos la
cantidad de 270 como el 100% y le
agregamos el 16% del iva es decir
queremos calcular el 116 por ciento sólo
multiplicamos 270 por 1 punto 16
obtenemos 300 13.2 como resultado de lo
que hay que pagar con todo e impuestos
sigue calculando porcentajes y haciendo
magia con estos trucos ahora vamos a
calcular el porcentaje que representan
los días que vamos a la escuela entonces
acomodamos el 7 como el total de días de
la semana que es nuestro 100% y el 5
como el número de días cuyo porcentaje
estamos buscando
este método se llama regla de tres y tal
vez ya lo conoces lo importante es
acomodar los tres datos que tenemos
los días con los días y los porcentajes
con los porcentajes a continuación vamos
a multiplicar los que estén cruzados
como haciendo el símbolo de la
multiplicación el 7 no tiene con quién
multiplicarse así que lo haremos con el
5 y el 100
y 5% nos da 500 ahora para que el 7 no
se sienta solito vamos a dividir el
resultado entre el número que haya
quedado solo es decir 500 entre 7 es
igual a 70 y 1.42 con muchos decimales
más pero sólo tomaremos estos dos y
listo el porcentaje de días de la semana
que voy a la escuela es el 71 punto 42
puedes usar el método que más te guste
sólo recuerda organizar muy bien tus
datos